ouais si michel peyrard
michel peyrard bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
grand reporter à paris match et vous
couvrez depuis 15 ans tous les conflits
de la planète du nicaragua à
l'afghanistan en passant par la
tchétchénie et le 9 octobre 2001 deux
jours après le début des frappes
américaines en afghanistan
vous êtes arrêté par les talibans
accusés d'espionnage et vous encourez la
peine de mort vous serez emprisonnait 26
jours avant d'être libérée et d'y
retourner pour retrouver votre géôliers
celui qui vous a sauvé la vie et
découvrir que vous aviez en fait échappé
de justesse à la mort
et puis aussi on en parlera qu'oussama
ben laden que les américains cherché
partout était en fait tranquillement à
djalalabad
à moins d'un kilomètre de votre prison
voilà vous raconter tout ça dans un
livre qui paraît chez pauvert qui
s'appelle poste numéro trois hôtes des
talibans par michel terrain
[Applaudissements]
michel peyrard merci d'avoir choisi tout
le monde en parle pour en parler
interview vérité alors le 8 octobre la
veille de votre capture vous êtes à
peshawar vous regarder la télévision des
images de la guerre et vous dites c'est
très bien écrit le bouquin vous dit
d'emblée j'ai détesté cette guerre si
discourtoise qu'elle s'invite et un
dimanche soir veille de bouclage il ya
pas pire
y a pas pire parce qu'on n'a pas le
temps on n'a pas le temps de travailler
alors votre bouquin c'est une réflexion
sur la guerre aussi vous dites j'aime
couvrir la guerre j'en aime les mauvais
goût les cadavres exhibé il ya un
plaisir à couvrir la guerre moi je
trouve que dans le dans la guerre il y a
il ya une des sociétés qui se dégage des
décotes des usages nos sociétés
occidentales sont réfugiés sont très
codifié dans la guerre souvent les gens
ne se la joue plus basse et plus à peine
de sept à jouer parce que la vie est par
essence éphémère donc les masques
tombent
j'ai l'impression parfois que le centre
de gravité l'huma se déplace et j'aime
la vérité des gens à ce moment là dans
la guerre se donne de l'intensité à la
vie c'est ça qui vous fascine une
certaine façon les journalistes trouvent
leur compte dans leur guerre dans la
guerre c'est pas la peine de se raconter
des histoires on aime ça ouais
et puis à cette idée d'aller voir
soi-même c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
les états majors organise des voyages 1
ce qu'on appelle le pool c'est à dire
pour un certain nombre de journalistes
et les trimbale comme ça ils leur
montrent ce qu'ils veulent bien leur
montrer et vous pendant la guerre du
koweït avec des copains vous aviez fait
un anti poule qui s'appelait fuck de
poule et et vous y alliez sens sans être
guidé par des militaires par les
militaires américains et alors il ya un
truc extraordinaire quand vous êtes
arrivé à koweït city s'étaient déguisés
en militaires vous êtes arrivé avant le
pool de journalistes et vous ai
découvert toutes les supercheries qui
était monté à usage des journalistes où
effectivement nous quand on est arrivé
on n'a pas découvert la quatrième armée
du monde qu'on nous vendait le package
paquet jeu médiatique des américains
nous disait que c'était on allait à on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir c'était
adolf hitler avait pas que saddam
hussein
l'amérique a toujours eu des s'attend
donc ça a été marié gaza était kadhafi
puisse arrêter saddam hussein je crois
que l'amérique par définition a besoin
d'eux a besoin de se découvrir comme ça
des amis à noter d'ailleurs que ce sont
souvent d'anciens amis de julie qu
envoyer l'armée irakienne soit disant la
quatrième armée du monde en fait vous
découvrez que c'est dégueu comme vous
dites dans votre bouquin et des enfants
désarmés démotivés et puis avait aussi
une fausse salle de supplices qui avait
été montée à usage des journalistes
lorsqu'on est arrivé à à koweit city on
a découvert à l'hôpital moubarak de du
centre ville une
une morgue où il y avait des gens qui
avaient été sublime supplier suppliciés
de torture l acide il y avait huit ou
une dizaine de cadavres je crois trois
ou quatre jours après tout ça avait été
organisée pour les besoins du pool pour
montrer à la presse américaine et acier
annan en particulier à quel point saddam
hussein était un set et s attend et
s'attend alors à peshawar c'est pas en
militaires que vous déguiser cette fois
c'est un talibane c'est à dire que vous
essayez une burqa alors c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que vous
vous souhaitez porter une burqa et vous
dites que d'abord cette vision
effectivement grillagé et en plus elles
n'ont pas le droit de tourner la tête à
droite ou à gauche parce que finalement
elles ne doivent pas regarder l'homme
donc elles sont un peu comme des chevaux
qui auraient des ornières qui auraient
des ornières
elles n'ont pas le droit d'avoir un
regard pour leurs geôliers pour les
hommes il ya effectivement beaucoup
d'accidents par exemple sur les sur les
routes en afghanistan parce que d'une
part le cadre grillagée limite extrême
dans la vision et d'autre part ils
peuvent pas tourner la tête
ouais alors vous faites un essai vous
faites une incurie fonctionne à vous et
partez du pakistan et en afghanistan
dans une ville qui s'appelle rost qui
est très important vraies places fortes
stratégique des taliban elle avoue gérer
ça marche
et là vous vous dites ça y est
maintenant je vais toujours à billom on
talibane je vais aller à kaboul mais
vous avez comme un pressentiment vous
avez une espèce de prévention 1
je me sens pas ce matin là il ya une
succession d'événements way d un
confrère pakistanais qui devait nous
accompagner qui est arrêté ensuite on a
plus le bon chauffeur
on a une espèce de pleutres de
chauffeurs lequel je n'ai aucune
confiance et j'aurais dû m'écouter à ce
moment là effectivement lors à ce moment
là
vouliez une rivière a passé il ya un bac
vous êtes dans un break
vous sortez du braque et vous savez
quand ils vont voir votre taille ils
vont comprendre que vous n'êtes pas une
femme et un homme
mais ce qui est très étonnant sur la
culture talibane c'est qu'à ce moment-là
il n'ose pas vous déshabiller sauce pas
d habiller les femmes
moi j'ai refusé quand même quand je suis
sorti sur le bac je me suis accroupi
très vite de façon à dissimuler ma
taille effectivement et donc il avait
quelques doutes puisque j'étais avec gt
avec le confrère pakistanais qu'ils
avaient reconnu mais ils se sont donnés
le temps de m'observait et puis
finalement ils ont quand même pas osé ce
qu'il était et est sûre à 70% il nous en
dit plus tard mais c'est 30% restants ça
les gêne et donc ils ont demandé une
vieille femme de venir me de venir
fouiller dont quatre mois je sente
xterra pdg enlever la peau elle ad
ailleurs et je me suis pris un vieux
coup de poing dans le dans le dans
l'oreille qui m'a assommé et puis à
partir de là j'étais j'étais bien
mouais le sable était chaud et je me
sente à l'aise plus en faites pas et
alors là vous êtes arrêté au départ
c'est assez courtois l'interrogatoire
ouais je passe plutôt bien et la voyais
arriver un type qui s'appelle tu admires
jawad
alors vous une description il se
trouvait dans mon bouquin profil camus
l'ip dédaigneuse claudique mans et vous
avez cette phrase tout en lui révèle une
adolescence frustré de celles qui
forment les bourreaux inspiré serre vous
sentez que ce n'est pas tellement
souffert quand il était petit
qu'effectivement il déteste la terre
entière
et là vous commencez à vraiment flippé
il a 24 ans vous apprendra après que
c'est un proche de ben laden qui va le
noir brun portant al qaïda ouais c'est
le responsable des services secrets pour
l'ensemble du sud de l'afghanistan
considéré comme un jeune prodige c'est
vrai qu'il avait quelques qualités
pas dépourvue de cruauté il est
responsable de milliers d'arrestations
arbitraires djalal abad et 2 et 2
probablement plusieurs dizaines
d'exécutions dont celle du fameux
commandant abdul haq qui est ce ce
commandant qui s'étaient infiltrés en
afghanistan pour tenter de rallier les
triples été tués tout de suite qui a été
tuée tout de suite parce qu'à mon avis
de l'été infiltré depuis le départ alors
vous au départ j'ai beau leur dire que
vous êtes journaliste et vous traite
d'espions un indice même les français
peuvent être espion ouais il y avait une
intégrale déclarations malencontreuses
on peut pas leur en vouloir mais du du
ministère de la défense qui avait dit
nous avons des espions en afghanistan je
ne savais pas je crois que c'était la
veille au matin
je n'en dis bien dans les temps qui
donne pas les photos à la télé au corps
donc j'étais un peu dans l'embarras
alors on fait ce qu'on appelle un city
tour c'est-à-dire un tour de ville vous
êtes exhibé vous est lapidé quand même
temps je prends des pirates est je
prends des pierres partout j'ai pas été
plus mal lotis dans la mesure où j'étais
debout donc j'étais en sang
effectivement mais mon un de mes
confrères pakistanais qui se trouvait à
l'arrière et et recevait des coups de
crosse des arabes parce qu'en fait il
est beaucoup d'arabes jalalabad est
donc je crois que on est resté 26 jours
ensemble en prison il n'a pas pu dormir
pendant 21 jours ils s'habillent était
bleu est alors plus tard quand vous en
parlerai avec vos geôliers
vous leur direz morale pourquoi me faire
faire ce tour de la ville et blanc comme
arme je leur reproche en permanence au
city tour oui je dise bas nous c'est
normal qu'on vous fasse ça parce que
nous on n'a pas la télé pour annoncer
votre capture comment vous voulez qu'on
fasse
c'est insensé et 100 joueurs ouais alors
al'inverse de ce personnage un autre qui
est beaucoup plus sympa dans votre
bouquin je vais le karité hiver 1 alors
lui il est sympathique d'emblée vous le
trouvez c'est bien dans ce bouquin de ce
cas le méchant je vous le trouver
sympathique d'emblée lépi peut-être
moins décérébrés par l'islamisme que les
autres il est entré en talibani un peu
par hasard
et puis pour des pour des intérêts ainsi
il a cessé il est il est à ben moi je le
trouve assez sympa dans la mesure où
j'ai l'impression qui m'a sauvé la vie
ben oui effectivement je viens à un
moment ça l'extraordinaire dans votre
bouquin c'est ça
[Musique]
et
c'est la sienne est absolument
incroyable on verra ça dans un film on
dirait le scénariste a pris de l'acide
vous êtes là par les bombardements
américains ou les talibans était sur le
toit de la prison
et puis effectivement je j'ai dû penser
à abandonner se trouve que match a été
longtemps installé sur les
champs-elysées donc je devais avoir une
vieille nostalgie et je me suis mis à
fredonner mais alors malgré moi parce
que j'avais une pression pour joe dassin
particulier aux champs elysées et ils
l'ont retenu il adore chanter et c'est
comme ça que joe dassin est entré au
panthéon de la guerre sainte sur le toit
de la prison les avions américains dans
le ciel les talibans jubile en compte
quand les frappes commence moi j'arrive
au deuxième jour des frappes
pour eux c'est c'est tout bénef c'est la
guerre a commencé le djihad a commencé
donc il y avait une espèce de liesse
très particulière avec les les termes
des ca
le spectacle était grandiose
[Musique]
oh
je me disais
alors quand vous entendez cette chanson
maintenant c'est que du bien quand même
ça me rappelle des bons souvenirs mais
surtout je les ai entendus à djalalabad
lorsque j'y suis retourné je crois dans
quelques années on a essayé mais pas
toujours
[Musique]
ben tu morts en afghanistan maintenant
oui il faudrait que je vois
éventuellement pour les doigts alors
vous découvrez les talibans de
l'intérieur et ça c'est très intéressant
c'est en ça que votre livre aussi très
intéressant c'est à dire que finalement
on voit des gens qui sont capable
d'autodérision qui sont loin de se
moquer d'eux mêmes ils sont marrants son
joueur il joue au volley ball ils
veulent constituer l'équipe des talibans
pour les jeux olympiques les vrais
méchants j'ai l'impression en lisant
votre bouquin c'est arabe sert ceux qui
sont venus et qui ont fait souche là-bas
quoi et qui s'est lassé la grée la vraie
découverte c'est à dire moi je suis
arrivé plutôt confiant ce même après
l'arrestation je pensais que je pouvais
m'en sortir en mesure où je vous avez
fréquenté en 96 ce que j'avais
complètement mésestimé c'était une
importance qui avait pris les arabes
et quand j'ai découvert que les talibans
les craignait réellement il en avait
peur il et d'écrivains prévisible
émotionnel alors pendant ce temps là
michel peyrard à l'extérieur il ya une
grande mobilisation pour vous évidemment
votre journal paris match qui s'occupe
très bien de ces algues grand reporter
quand ils sont dans la merde il faut le
dire les autorités françaises aussi bien
sûr et vous vous en doutez pas si vous
êtes dans cette prison et puis vous
savez pas tout ça vous en doutez un
petit peu mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment
qu'on en doute même pas du tout je suis
je suis à ce point naïf que j'imaginais
on parle de libération c'est à dire à
partir du 12e jour j'imagine repartir
pas le même endroit très discrètement
par l' agence de mormant en remettant la
burqa pourquoi voulons pas tuer au début
j'ai il était quelle ville il était
question qui me tue le premier soir
jusque quand carine ever donc le
directeur de la prison appelles tu as du
meilleur djaouad pour demander mon
shalwar kamiz donc la tunique
pakistanaise parce que la gt
pratiquement jeté tortues ne meurent
jamais rien tu admires lui répond le
français est mort demain donc c'est de
lever tir kaboul s'est opposé à notre
exécution des deux ou troisième jour je
crois qu'on le doit beaucoup à leurs
fans qui est donc mon confrère
pakistanais qui avaient aidé des amitiés
notamment aux ministères des affaires
étrangères et à partir de ce moment là
je crois que notre vie n'étaient plus en
danger
je dois passer doit quand même c'était
chaud
parler maintenant donc de tf1 et de
canal plus interview vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors xavier couture d'après le journal
le monde vous n'aviez pas prévenu
etienne mougeotte dont vous étiez un des
plus proches collaborateurs de votre
nomination à la tête de canal+ c'est
vrai oui c'est vrai mais vous savez ce
que c'est tiré on a toujours dit faire
vos feux pendant je négocie avec la hune
j'avais même si sûr sur l'autre ligne
j'étais en pourparlers avec arte je
voulais me casser cette chaîne qui était
la lune ça c'est certain mais rien
n'était fait encore il est prévenu
personne
et alors quant à patrick le livre les
prévenus sur son portable il était à
l'aéroport il partait à moscou et vous
l'appelez voulu dit ouais je m'en vais
quoi c'est pas un peu brutal mais non je
ne savais pas qu'il était à l'aéroport
je ne savais pas qu'ils partaient à
moscou en plus j'ai une excuse c'est que
je m'en branle est complètement donc
c'est vrai mais est ce que le lait et
mougeotte savez que depuis deux ans vous
aviez des discussions avec jean marie
messier
d'abord pour remplacer michel denisot
ensuite pour prendre la direction du
pôle production
c'est un petit métier je crois que tout
se sait et chacun profite bénéficient
des appels d'offres et chaque année je
pense qu'on est tous sur le marché et
que chacun a des connexions avec les
autres chaînes vous savez de quoi on
parle kiri puisque vous même on voit
régulièrement sur téva ou 2 1 et puis
vous avions pas parlé avec la une aussi
oui absolument
et voilà bien vous connaissiez pierre
lescure oui je le connais oui j'en ai
mis à vous c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie c'est quelqu'un qui sait
partir la tête haute sans stock options
et je lui dis bravo
est ce que jean marie messier ne nous a
pas choisi un petit peu par défaut
finalement parce qu'on dit vous n'avez
pas la carrure du poisson dit beaucoup
de gens de métier 10 ne s'est pas un xxl
quoi couture dont jean-marie messier
mais jean marie messier
a besoin de résultats il a des
actionnaires qui demande des comptes et
je vais remercier a besoin de personnes
qui savent faire rentrer des sous dans
le financier s'est pas trop votre
domaine on se souvient de du sport
excusez-moi leur parler enfin le
quotidien le sport qui était quand même
un échec financier grave et en
artistique ça va être très difficile
pour vous le saviez pas ce qu'en interne
les gens comme farrugia chabat gaccio
vont sans doute partir le personnel est
remonté les syndicats monsieur cholet le
responsable de la cfdt a dit je promets
à xavier couture des jours difficiles
les gens de l'extérieur aussi des gens
comme jamais les gens comme deux comme
beaucoup d'artistes vont pas vouloir
travailler pour vous vous avez géré ça
comment mais on va gérer ça très bien
puisqu'on n'a pas besoin d'artistes sur
canal+ puisqu'il n'y a pas d' artistique
et qu'on n'est pas concerné par
l'artiste vraiment des annonceurs on va
faire rentrer donc des recettes on va
mettre beaucoup d'écrans et on va mettre
des films et du foot ou la place à
l'artistique là dans la rue tristan
qu'il ait déjà fait puisque le film
qu'on l'achète il a déjà été fait par et
j'en ai écrit et travaillés par les
artistes dakar oui c'est vous êtes de
chemins étaient des gens c'est logique
qu'on aura une compo pas comprendre sa
jeune âge ses cadres
fonctionnement qui bien sûr alors bien
sûr j'ai tenté de rassurer tout le monde
et xavier c'est normal le milieu du
cinéma en leur promettant vous
continuerez à leur donner ce que canal+
leur donne chaque année
bien sûr même si messier veut la fin de
l'exception culturelle française il l'a
dit rassuré de [ __ ] tout le monde
toujours dans l'ordre d'arrivée en y
quand tout le monde est ce que j'en
arrive ici et xavier vous aurez pas
engagé pour faire le sale boulot
finalement pour virer tout le monde a
dit ça de de bruyne il s'est ensuite de
beaucoup de personnes je crois que le
sale boulot a beaucoup été fait à canal
et à part deux techniciens de surface il
reste plus grand monde a viré
et maintenant voilà le sale boulot a été
fait vous avez confiance en jean marie
messier
bien sûr je veux un peu confiance à
quelqu'un qui ment embaucher et qui a de
la gueule à la finesse de 2,2 sentir en
moi la personne idéale pour redresser la
barre du bateau canadien ce qui est en
train de couler avec est d'aider des
trublions comme alain chabat déjà mais
vous avez vu dominique faruggia non mais
vous en voulez plus de ces gens là pour
moi ces gens là méritent la fosse
commune
alors imaginez que j'en arrivai ci
soient débarqués imaginer qu'ils font
quand même c'est bon c'est bon
imaginez xavier que jean marie messier
soit débarqué mercredi et qui soit plus
patron de vivendi universal vous avez
quitté tf1 vous n'irez pas sur canal
vous allez être comment un petit peu ni
canicule ridicule je l'ait déjà été
donc j'assumerai vous savez sera pas la
première fois que je serai ridicule et
et voilà risquez de vous retrouver au
chômage et xavier oui bien sûr mais moi
je suis un battant je pars je pars
battant moi je vais gagner ce match bien
sûr d'être courageux je suis très
courageux la preuve c'est que vous êtes
venus ici ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'harry demulder aux côtés de
naomi campbell de cindy crawford de
claudia schiffer de linda evangelista et
de elie mcpherson vous avez été donc une
star des podiums avait fait la une de
tous les grands magazines du monde
c'était l'époque des top models qu'est
ce qu'un top model avait de plus quand
même qu'un normal en fait c'était un mot
qui tout d'un coup est remonté à la
surface et tout d'un coup on était plus
des mannequins et on était des top
models et je crois que c'était les
filles qui étaient vraiment sur le
devant de la scène qui était pas
seulement d
et les filles sur des couvertures mais
qui convoyait à la télévision
connaissaient leur nom leur nid en fait
la célébrité quoi ouais alors ensuite
quitté le métier vous avez fait des
voyages aux caraïbes
vous avez fait la tournée des [ __ ]
vous avez fait des tentatives déjà pour
enregistrer un disque pour jouer la
comédie
et puis un soir ici sur ce plateau vous
avez avait craqué c'était
en fait des choses qui sont remontés à
la surface qui ont fait que tout d'un
coup il y avait de la paranoïa en plus
mais il y avait des choses vraies
ensuite vous avez passé trois mois en
clinique à lutter contre la dépression
et aujourd'hui vous êtes de retour et
vous dites je me sens une autre femme
toute neuve la même en mieux
bah oui on change un petit peu des
personnalités je crois que quand on va
chercher très loin dans soi mais on est
toujours la même personne mais oui mieux
je suis plus serein je vis plus
l'instant avant j'avais toujours
tendance à les regarder en arrière
d'être nostalgique ou avoir toujours un
but
regarder vers le futur et aujourd'hui je
vis vraiment au jour le jour quoi est ce
que cette souffrance vous endurci est ce
que vous sentez plus forte qu'avant moi
je crois toujours être quelqu'un de très
fort d'un côté et très fragiles de nos
la souffrance de appris la compassion ma
souffrance est toujours été là pendant
ma vie c'était quelque chose donc je
lutter constamment contre donc je suis
toujours été quelqu'un qui avait eu
beaucoup de compassion
maintenant vous avez connu le meilleur
de la vie le pire vous savez tout mais
on sait jamais tout est ce que les psys
vous ont vraiment aidé dans cette
affaire et j'en ai vu des des abrutis
excuse moi le mot il y en a vraiment ils
ont rien compris du tout et là je
oui j'en ai un que je vois de temps en
temps je le vois même pas souvent parce
que j'ai plus besoin mais j'aime bien de
temps en temps pour remettre les
pendules à l'heure et
quelque part aussi ce qu'on a manqué
dans son éducation où la vie ne nous a
pas appris ils voulaient expliquent lui
vous juge pas au moins ils écoutent
alors vous êtes passés de l'autre côté
du miroir vous savez maintenant que le
bonheur n'est plus obligatoirement lié à
l'argent à la gloire à la vie facile
mais peut-être à l'amour c'est un amour
des tâches et moi c'est un amour où on
s'approprie pas quelque chose ou
quelqu'un c'est quelque chose de plus
spirituel pour moi j'espérais rencontrer
l'homme de votre vie karen j pense pas
ouais
oui parce que si vous y pensez ça va
vous obliger à la rtnc tu as a way
et puis il faut pas avoir une idée trop
trop préconçues non plus faut pas avoir
une idée en tête parce que sinon on
n'est plus disponible pour les hommes
qui peuvent arriver
ben oui c'est vrai que par la solitude
des fois on fait les mauvais choix on
préfère être avec quelqu'un même s'il
nous convient pas tout à fait parce
qu'on veut pas être seul ou des choses
comme ça oui quel type d'homme vous
cherchez mais je cherche pas quel type
d'homme vous aimeriez rencontrer à la
fois j'aimerais quelqu'un je trouve ça
très difficile peut-être un homme tout
simple ouais voulu avoir des enfants
ah oui j'aimerais beaucoup mais pour ça
il faudrait quand même que je trouve ça
fun ça vous demande un effort d'être là
ce soir
non non non après la dernière émission
je veux pas faire du tout de venir ici
non mais c'était vraiment très aimable
de pas l'avoir déficit c'est la moindre
des choses
mulet
[Musique]
comme müller d'un mois des âmes bravo
m
en vendée si c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
willow des ingés bonsoir on est à sainte
foy les lyon il y à 41 ans parcours
départ assez classique école de commerce
diplôme
et puis dans les années 80 vous créer
une radio libre avec jean edern hallier
exact ensuite entre deux petits boulots
vous écrivez un livre où vous évoquez
des tours de cristal qui disparaissent
dans l'apocalypse est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est la conclusion même du
livre puisque c'est une immense vision
de l'apocalypse qui clôture ce ce
premier livre et je les voyais comme un
symbole de new york bien sûr
prémonitoire
peut-être mais la grande aventure de
votre vie justement c'est l'amérique
d'abord la californie ensuite new york
vous adhérez au rêve américain et en
1997 vous fonder une société destinée à
aider les sociétés américaines qui
veulent investir en europe et
inversement
également vous organiser des expositions
pour de jeunes artistes américains
vous installez vos bureaux au 47e étage
du wall trade center ces bureaux vous
les adorez 1
je les adore vous dites une transparence
des murs en verre une table en verre un
lieu de paix de sérénité de réflexion
dans ce dans cette ville de new york est
une ville extrêmement bruyante
c'était un lieu où il y avait un silence
merveilleux presque magique
les gens qui étaient dans les étages
supérieurs par exemple pouvait passer
l'hiver entier dans les nuages dans le
coton et nous on était à la bonne à la
bonne hauteur c'est à dire qu'on avait
parfois le coton aussi mais parfois on
était aussi au dessus des nuages
souvent on était un an d'un soleil
radieux comme le temps new yorkais alors
le soir des fois vous quittez votre
bureau du wall trade center vous marchez
sur le pavé vous vous retournez et vous
dites c'est pareil [ __ ] je suis dans
le wall trade center complètement ans le
world trade center vous en parlait très
bien dans votre livre parce qu'en fait
c'est une ville en l'air il ya
énormément de gens qui équilibre là
dedans c'est une utopie des gens de
toutes les races de toutes les classes
de toutes les religions 115 nationalités
et qui vivait harmonieusement
et puis un jour ce jour c'est le 11
septembre 2001 comme vous dites
les [ __ ] ils ont pété mon bureau
interview vérité
[Musique]
alors bruno ménager dans septembre 2001
votre réveil sonne à 4 heures du matin
pourquoi parce que victoria un
déplacement professionnel et elle va
saint paul mais n'y a plus et elle part
très tôt elle part de l'aéroport de
newark dans le new jersey tout un
certain nombre d'avions ont décollé au
sinon un avion suicide
moi je me lève vers 6h30 alors va te
faire victoria est parti pour pour ses
affaires vous prenez votre métro
normalement pour rejoindre le world
trade center et à 8h45 vous êtes avec
vos deux employés vous commencez votre
journée de travail
le stagiaire est en retard oui ou par
non à reims et les trains du du nord de
new york du crin et les quêtes journée
normale j'en ai merveilleuse et à ce
moment là vous entendez vous dites dans
votre bouquin un énorme vrombissement
vous reconnaissez tout de suite le bruit
d'un avion
oui parce que je voyage beaucoup et
encore une fois l une des magies de ce
lieu c'était le silence
donc je le remarque immédiatement
comprenez pas sur le moment vous relevé
la tête et moment vous levez la tête
vous entendez un impact d'une violence
inouïe et trois secondes plus tard vous
voyez passer par la fenêtre devant vous
oui des débris débutera elle vous voyez
sub médusés je vois passer devant devant
mes fenêtres et de mes employés sont
médusés aussi on voit passer des tonnes
d'oeufs de morceaux de ferraille ouais
de kérosène de verre et on sait pas ce
que c'est on comprend pas très inquiet à
ce moment là non non non parce que le
bâtiment hausse il vraiment très très
longuement et il tente pendant une
vingtaine de secondes
trente secondes je sais pas exactement
et à tel point que suis-je obligé de
tenir une de mes employés parce que j'ai
peur qu'elle s'effondre et dans le
bureau tout tout bouge les tableaux un
tableau se casse la figure une statue
est vraiment va si fortement mais non on
n'a pas peur on pense que je le redis g7
remarque idiote je le redis et vous
inquiétez pas c'est un avion qui a
percuté le bâtiment
ouais oui parce qu'en 45 il ya une
erreur de pilotage avait amené déjà un
avion à s'écraser contre le vampire
state building oui je ne sais pas oui
oui c'est à ça que je pense a
immédiatement et je me dis c'est un
avion un pilote qui a qui a mal mais je
pense pas un avion de ligne a
certainement pas et je pense pas à un
attentat en coin
ouais ouais votre seule réflexion selon
l'aci vous dire c'est qu'on va perdre
des journées de travail parce que vous
êtes un entrepreneur c'est en amérique
n'est pas pris évidemment conscience de
l'ampleur du drame
et puis à ce moment là un de vos
employés ouvre la porte qui donne sur le
couloir et à ce moment là quand même
vous voyez de la fumée se sent kérosène
oui alors que notre bureau était dans un
état tout à fait acceptable on ouvre la
porte et là c'est déjà une certaine
dévastation parce que les uns les
plafonds sont effondrés mais il ya de la
fumée et une odeur de kérosène
épouvantable
plus tard quand gvt a cure et il ya même
des de l'eau qui coule dans les dents
dans les cages d'ascenseur de service
ouais on voit pas très bien il ya
quelqu'un qui s'enfuit dans la pénombre
et mes employés ont ont peur parce que
c'est une femme qui a eu à subir
l'attendent à 93 et quand je leur dis de
partir ils suivent immédiatement c'est
ça alors vous rester seul dans le bureau
vous employez sont descendus 1
alors assez tranquillement d'ailleurs
vous faites vos sauvegardes
informatiques vous raccrochez vos
tableaux vous éteignez la photocopieuse
c'est bien je voyais abl
le tour ouais je fais le tour je coupe
tout et je fais une sauvegarde
informatique
mettez de l'ordre dans votre bureau vous
dit tiens je vais rester plusieurs jours
sans revenir donc voilà je veux que ça
soit bien que ce soit que ce soit rangé
et alors on n'entend rien parce que les
haut parleurs ne marchait pas aller haut
parleurs d' alerte sur le 47e étage on
est en train de refaire les les systèmes
d'alarmé
donc j'ai pas de sentiment d'urgence
immédiate vous prenez l'escalier assez
tranquillement au bout d'un moment il ya
47 étages à descendre évidemment la
descente va durer cinquante minutes sans
beaucoup d'affolement d'ailleurs
effectivement les gens ben un petit peu
comme moi je trouve qu'ils ont une
journée de travail interrompu trouve ça
désagréable mais tout le monde est très
calme très civique très ordonnée et en
descend
le landais des 47 étages pendant que des
lits trafic qui se densifie
pas de panique les gens parlent des
affaires en cours il maquille et
commente les résultats sportifs de la
veille comme voilà comme ça
à un moment il ya un type quand même qui
reçoit un texto qui lui annonce que la
tour numéro deux a été attaquée mais
personne panique les gens continuent à
descendre
il ya quand même un truc est un peu plus
inquiétant annoncé quand vous un brûlé
vous double et là vous dites dans votre
bouquin les gens détournent assez
pudiquement le regard
oui et je pense que ça fait partie de
ces défauts ses mécanismes de défense
qu'on a tous eu dans des circonstances
difficiles
on voulait peut-être pas voir ce qui se
passait et puis en plus on comprenait
pas parce que ces gens étaient n'avait
plus de poney plus de cheveux étaient
complètement brûlé et tout au long de la
tour dans les escaliers de c'est tout on
entendait s'écrit priorité priorités et
les gens descendent des blessures en
priorité et puis des pompiers qui
montrent aussi harnachés alors
évidemment il ya une espèce de va et
vient comme ça dans ses escaliers mais
tout ça est avec beaucoup de calme comme
on l'a dit vous arrivez sur le parvis du
wall trade center oui je suis sorti en
souterrain les gens qui sont sortis sur
le parvis et qui était parti en même
temps que moi son décès n'est donc
je suis sorti en souterrain en sortant
dans la rue je me suis retourné j'ai vu
ce bâtiment en feu là j'ai compris que
c'était très grave
et puis effectivement je me suis
retourné une deuxième fois et je n'ai
pas vu parce qu'il y avait ce monstre
kim qui arrivait sur nous le nuage tueur
le killer klout les nuages ce tueur est
ce que j'appellerais plus tard aussi
vraiment le baiser de la mort et c'est
parce que ça dépasse l'entendement en un
instant alors que dans cette rue il y
avait une vie extraordinaire de services
de secours qui étaient dans tous les
sens de voitures de d'ambulances de
gyrophares partout de sirène soudain
s'abat sur nous cette masse monstrueuse
et tout devient silencieux et c la nuit
et donc là à ce moment là l'esprit est
plus capable de procéder à l'analyse et
c'est le subconscient qui reçoit tout et
on est terrorisé et maintenant je
comprends ce que c'est qu'un traumatisme
parce que sa dépense tellement ça
dépasse tellement l'entendement que le
cerveau est plus capable de l'accepter
ce nuage il avait quelque consistance
moi j'appelle ça de la matière fluide
parce qu'il ya une accumulation
extrêmement dense de cendres de débris
de gravats de poutrelles de verre
j'ai gardé la cendre que j'ai recueilli
sûrement sur mon costume ce que je
considère qu'elle est sacrée et
qu'effectivement dans toute cette
cendrillon est peut-être des morceaux
d'hommes alors à ce moment là vous vous
réfugier derrière le pilier d'une banque
vous êtes tout noir évidemment couverts
de 2 c de cette chose quoi de cette
matière fluide comme vous dites vous
êtes plus d'oxygène peut plus respirer
parce qu'évidemment ce nuage a envahi
toute l'atmosphère
vous croyez être mort en fait à ce
moment là - où mon subconscient est
persuadé que
je suis mort alors se traduira par des
choses invraisemblables
parce que un petit peu plus tard quand
je me promène dans la rue mon esprit
continuer à capter des signaux de ce que
la vie continue mais à l'intérieur lui
persuadé des morts alors j'ai
l'impression de devenir complètement fou
et j'ai l'impression que quand on parle
de ces gens qui sont devenus amnésiques
en a retrouvé bien il ya quelques jours
seulement je comprends tout à fait ce
qui s'est passé ils ont juste pas
résisté vous citez pas loin ben moi j'ai
cru vraiment devenir un parfait
alors là il ya un agent du fbi qui vous
fait entrer dans la banque bondissait de
sauver vous retrouvez d'autres gens
d'ailleurs maintenant qu'ils sont aussi
noir que vous alors là évidemment il ya
les bons sentiments on a beaucoup parlé
ici aux etats-unis dans les médias mais
aussi ben vous découvrez la nature
humaine c'est à dire qu'il ya des
profiteurs il ya des pilleurs il ya des
vautours
on vous propose par exemple un jour des
bureaux gratuit vous est vachement
content on y tient les mecs sont
solidaires imhoff des bureaux gratuit et
le type vous dis que ça c'est valable
pendant deux mois et qu'à partir de la
fin du deuxième mois il faudra payer
2000 dollars par poste de travail
ce qui fait beaucoup d'argent tous les
cas beaucoup plus cher que ce que vous
payez ual trade center c'est difficile
de découvrir cet aspect si la nature
humaine
enfin c'est pas une découverte non plus
mais les hommes sont les hommes mais
simplement dans ces circonstances ça
prend un relief particulier
effectivement alors tout ça en plus dans
une psychose terrible un état de guerre
quoi peur de l'anthrax à ce moment-là
vous chercher avec victoria votre épouse
des masques à gaz sur internet enfin se
dire c est ce qu un sentiment de
vengeance vous a aidé à ce moment là au
début j'ai eu une violente pour tous ces
gens maintenant c'est le mépris et rien
de plus ben laden vous l'auriez tuer
ben laden je pense que tous mes idéaux
ont volé en éclats et que j'ai plus
aucune certitude aujourd'hui sur ce que
c'est que sur la punition qu'on doit
infliger à des gens pareils et que je
croyais que les idéaux c'était éternelle
et j'étais contre la peine de mort et
maintenant je me pose de sérieuses
questions
oui parce que on peut pas se les traits
se laisser traiter comme ça c'est pas
possible
vous trouvez normal le sort que les
américains réservé aux prisonniers de la
base de guantanamo par exemple moi je
trouve que si c'est des criminels ils
sont encore bien traités parce que quand
on affiche tant de souffrances aux gens
on prend ses responsabilités d'abord et
on les assume jusqu'au bout penser
qu'ils méritent la façon dont on les
traite
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas volé la guerre
en afghanistan et y est pour les
bombardements de civils vous pas pour la
gaine mais après j'ai compris que
c'était important de répondre et je
crois que je me suis sentie rassurée
rassuré de ce que les gens qui sont
supposés nous défendre nous défendre et
oui je pense qu'elle était nécessaire ce
biais pour moi y ait aucun doute c'est
vrai qu'un an après les attentats du
world trade center l'antiaméricanisme
n'a jamais été aussi fort en europe 55 %
des européens jugent le comportement
américain pas étranger à ces attentats
c'est beaucoup 55 % des européens en
france et 63 % des gens qui pensent non
pas que les américains n'ont pas volé
c'est un peu exagéré mais que leur
comportement est pas étranger aux
attentats oui je trouve quelque chose de
monstrueux là dedans parce que comment
un très rapidement
quand on dit ils n'ont pas volé vraiment
on oublie on oublie tout ce qui s'est
passé et il n'y a pas d'actes
il n'y a pas de cause ya pas de défense
de causes qui justifie un acte pareil
voici que c'est une attitude munich oise
je pense qu'il ya certains roland
munichois dans tout ça et je pense que
on est très injuste à l'égard des états
unis parce que ils prennent des
responsabilités souvent que le monde
refuse de prendre
et après tout les européens ont des
idéaux et il faut prendre les moyens de
les défendre finalement alors vous savez
qu'on soupçonne l'arabie saoudite de
financer al qaïda sur les 19 pirates y
en avait 15 qui étaient saoudiens
mais les usa évidemment ne peuvent pas
s'en prendre à l'arabie saoudite aussi
directement les familles des victimes le
fond les familles des victimes du 11
septembre ont attaqué au tribunal des
banques saoudiennes des organisations
caritatives et trois membres de la
famille royale est ce que ça remet pas
en cause votre attachement au système
américain de voir que finalement leurs
vrais amis l'ont pratiquement identifié
mais que pour des raisons mercantiles
ils peuvent pas s'y attaquer parce que
l'arabie saoudite al pétrole oui vous
savez et je pense que c'est pas le
système américain qui est en cause dans
cette histoire c'est l'intérêt des états
et on sait que les états parfois se
conduisent pas forcément comme ils le
souhaitent et le rêve américain ou où
tout ce qui est ça n'a rien à voir
et je crois à l'heure actuelle que
effectivement tout le monde y compris
nous en europe sommes bien heureux
d'avoir cette source d'approvisionnement
pétrolière donc c'est du réalisme c'est
la réalité qu'on appelle le réalisme
politique
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui est prévu
à la place du wall trade center sur ce
qui s'appelle aujourd'hui ground zero
aujourd'hui je suis je suis un peu déçu
parce qu'ils étaient présentés ouais
parce qu'effectivement ça n'a pas l'élan
cavell de rock 7 5
pour moi le world trade center tout le
monde a vu comme un symbole de
domination là encore et puissance
américaine c'était un témoin du du génie
humain et on verra les concours sont pas
encore terminées je pense que tout le
monde va se remettre sur la planche à
dessin
si les tours sont reconstruites à cet
endroit là vous retournerez vous y
installer immédiatement allé
immédiatement parce que j'ai un grand
attachement au lieu je crois que ça
serait bien de pouvoir retourner là bas
et puis une vue magnifique oui vous
ferez quoi le 11 septembre
le 11 septembre je voudrais avec ceux
qui m'ont aidé d'abord est qu'ils ont
vécu ça j'aimerais aussi revoir les deux
femmes qui qui m'ont aidé quand je suis
revenu du world trade center
j'étais complètement couvert de cendres
j'étais hébété
je ressemblais à un fantôme et je voyais
bien devant moi tout le monde s'écarte
est et moi je rêvais que d'une chose
c'est que les gens me prennent dans
leurs bras
et puis personne s'approcher bien sûr
tous qui êtes tous on avait peur et je
me rappelle que
un moment sur broadway deux femmes
noires sont approchés de moi et je vois
très bien dans quel magasin un travail
sont approchés de moi et puis ils m'ont
fait rentrer et m'en donner un verre
d'eau puis ensuite tellement dit vas-y
appel mais on va composer le numéro pour
toi et un simplement l on appelait
appelé appelé puis ont pas réussi à
appeler ni victor est un animal en donc
ces femmes là je m'en allais revoir les
acceptant vous arrivez à vivre avec ça
en vous maintenant j'arrive à vivre avec
ça en moi c'est pas facile parce que
c'est comme un invité que vous avez vous
n'avez pas sollicité et il se manifeste
selon son son bon gré mais est ce assez
c'est horrible merci
[Applaudissements]
habsheim
oui donc vous avez 35 ans vous êtes
professeur en électrotechnique à
montpellier vous êtes le frère de
zacarias moussaoui qui est inculpé
depuis décembre 2001 c'était le premier
inculpé par la justice américaine pour
les attentats du 11 septembre il est
soupçonné d'avoir été le 20e pirate aux
ordres du réseau al qaïda six chefs
d'accusation pèsent contre lui dont
quatre sont passibles de la peine de
mort
le procès débutera le 6 janvier 2003 ce
verdict en plus est une véritable épée
de damoclès sur les relations franco
américaines puisque zacarias moussaoui
votre frère est de nationalité française
et qu'en france comme vous le savez
évidemment on a aboli la peine de mort
alors vous publiez zacarias moussaoui
mon frère chez denoël un pacte avec la
collaboration de la journaliste florence
boukila interview vérité
[Musique]
alors le 13 septembre 2001 vous roulez
sur le plateau de milo entre mende et
montpellier c'est jeudi
la semaine est finie la nuit tombe vous
écouter la radio france info
hélas dans l'immensité des cévennes vous
entendez une voix qui dit votre nom
moussaoui oui elle dit zacarias
moussaoui franco algérien a été arrêté
en relation avec les attentats du 11
septembre
depuis le 17 août et je crois qu'ils
avaient ajouté un prénom ahmed ou un
autre prénom
oui et puis disait franco-algérien donc
ma première réaction c'était de dire
zacarias moussaoui franco algérien bon
c'est pas c'est pas franco marocain il
disait à puis il ajoutait il disait né à
saint jean de luz
donc là ma gorge serrée et alors on va
commencer par le commencement votre père
était carreleur au maroc quand il a
rencontré votre mère qui à l'époque
avait 14 ans alors on n'a jamais su en
fait si votre mère avait voulu de toute
force quitter
son foyer pour se marier avec votre père
ou au contraire si elle était mariée de
force
ma mère dit qu elle a été mariée de
force ma grand mère dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier
mon oncle dit que c'est elle qui a voulu
se marier ma tante dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier il ya l'essentiel
n'est pas là
en tout cas c'est clair que des années
plus tard elle en a gardé une douleur et
une souffrance
elle s'en est largement exprimés
l'essentiel pour elle il est là en fait
c'est que ce mariage au départ c'était
une douleur pas pour elle alors deux
filles naissent et puis votre père
décide d'émigrer en france en 1965 sur
la côte basque et vous laissez vous donc
en 1967 et votre frère
zacharias en 1968 et trois ans après en
vos parents divorcent et vous partez
tous les deux avec votre mère à mulhouse
ou votre mère a trouvé du travail alors
pourquoi mulhouse
alors je ne sais pas j'étais trop jeune
je ne sais pas je sais qu'on s'est
retrouvé dans un dans un orphelinat qui
s'appelle le home saint jean oui parce
que votre mère peut pas vous gardez donc
mais à la dass j'imagine que ça doit
être des moments terribles pour elle et
c'est vrai que cet endroit pour nous
c'était un endroit un petit peu d'effroi
en même temps on était rassuré parce que
il y avait des parquets en bois il y
avait de gros édredon il faisait chaud
c'était bien chauffé et en même temps on
était un petit peu effrayé parce qu'on
n'avait pas nos parents et puis on
voyait tous ces gens nous disaient c'est
un orphelinat
donc vous comprenez chaque jour comme si
on était des invités comme si on allait
partir demain 1
mais à chaque jour en succès des
annonces a duré un an oui ça a duré plus
d'un an
ça a marqué acariès vous pensé cette
séparation de sa mère je pense que ça a
marqué toute la famille je pense que sa
marque et toute la famille parce que
dans cet orphelinat je pense que c'est
des endroits un petit peu où il n'y a
pas d'autorité parentale pour les
éducateurs sarah pense pas la famille ça
remplace pas les parents mais alors en
plus quand votre père vient vous voir
vous partez au courant parce que votre
mère vous a expliqué que votre père
était un méchant qui lui a fait du mal
donc quand vous voyez votre père
s'approcher pour vous parler vous partez
en courant et d'ailleurs il finit par se
lasser
il vient plus et puis un jour votre mère
vous dis ben vous voyez vous a laissé
tomber ben oui c'est triste
pas quelque chose mais c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne comprenait pas nous d'un
côté on avait notre mère qui nous disait
que qui nous montrait son affection qui
nous avait extirpé de l'orphelinat pour
nous c'était c'est formidable c'était
une héroïne pour nous et puis notre côté
on avait ce père qui était absent et qui
était accusé de tous les maux donc pour
pour nous c'était pas difficile de le
fuir s'était pas de racines quand ils
arrivent et vous partiez en partant en
courant en partant au courant d'ailleurs
je me raconte cet épisode dans le livre
il venait nous chercher nous a fait
monter dans une 4l et en deux 2 ans et
regardent avec mon frangin ouvert chacun
une porte et on a sauté en courant et on
s'est sauvés
qu'apprend on l'a plus revu pendant des
années parce qu'il s'est lassé il a fini
par se lasser
alors un jour votre maire annonce que
vous avez quitté l'est de la france pour
vous installer à narbonne et zacharias
lui veut rester à mulhouse
parce qu'il espère devenir joueur de
hand ball professionnel et c'est une
vraie déchirure pour lui c'est de ce
départ pour narbonne
oui c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qui
m'a marqué c'est quelque chose ce même
des années plus tard une qualité la fac
il en parlait encore avec un avec du
regret parce que il s'éclatait il était
dans un club les ex ptt mulhouse il joue
au handball il était reconnu il avait le
poste de pivot
il était très performant il était très
apprécié et puis toujours en un ma mère
nous a sorti une carte à la maison nous
a dit bon on va y dans le sud au soleil
on va voter
on va décider ensemble qui quelle ville
on va choisir on a pris une carte on a
mesuré sur la carte à distance avec la
mère la plus proche c'est et narbonne
donc on a dit on va aller à narbonne en
tous les cas pour zakaria quelque chose
se brise il en gardera toujours une
certaine rancoeur vous dites dans votre
livre une certaine amertume
moi je dirais c'est comme une fêlure une
petite fêlure qui vient se mettre après
une autre fêlures je me suis rendu
compte avec du recul que il n'y a pas
d'élément clé il ya des petites fêlures
des plus marque des coups de canifs
troisième fêlures l'arrivée à narbonne
alors là c'est terrible parce que vous
êtes marocain mais vous êtes assez assez
noir de peau et vous avé l'accent
alsacien
alors évidemment quand vous arrivez à
narbonne pour les gens là bas cette
espèce de martien en quelque sort par
défaut ça fait un campus arrivé comme ça
et que vous parlez comme ça
c'est pas très courant voyez là ça fait
plutôt sourire mais voilà maintenant
quand on est adulte en comprendre les
enfants c'est pas quelque chose
d'évident
oui alors il faut vous expliquer à tout
le monde la vérité faut vous expliquez
vous êtes arabe en fait donc son général
on n'a pas besoin de l'expliquer obligé
d'expliquer ça des fois on nous prend on
nous prenait pour des antilles et quand
nous pourrons encore vous prendre pour
un entier qu'on est enfant c'est ça va
c'est plutôt sympathique
le contact est plutôt sympathique les
antilles le rhum la vie marine
c'est plutôt sympa et un contact qui se
fait mais comme on dit arabe maghrébin
là tout de suite ça devient plus lourd
alors adolescent vous êtes plutôt sage
parce que vous avez qu'une peur c'est
d'avoir un casier judiciaire et ne pas
pouvoir faire des études poussées
d'ailleurs à l'époque zacharias est très
très droit il dit attention il faut pas
qu'en face de conneries quoi exactement
je crois que c'est le marque le passage
à à l'orphelinat qui nous a fait prendre
conscience de ça qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait pas laisser passer les
opportunités de formation est depuis
très jeune c'est mon frère qui me
poussait qui me dit attention il faut
qu'on fasse des études faut pas que
qu'on se laisse aller parce que dans le
quartier on habitait une invitée la cité
razimbaud à narbonne c'est cité hlm des
bâtiments de quatre étages une quinzaine
de blocs des terrains vagues les gamins
qui traîne qui squattent dans les halls
qui tiennent les murs l'environnement
c'est pas un environnement créé
traîtrise épanouissement très ouverts
quoi c c'est le monde de la stagnation
on attend que le temps passait végétatif
voilà alors côté études ça va pas si mal
mais côté familial ça s'arrange pas du
tout un jour vous promener dans la rue à
narbonne avec votre votre frère
zacharias et il ya quelqu'un qui vous
arrête comme ça qui vous dit mais vous
n'êtes pas les fils moussaoui vous alors
vous dites oui oui bien sur wii vous
connaissez notre père et l'homme vous
réponds oui j'étais en prison avec lui
notre première réaction ça a été de se
regarder et puis de regarder s'il ya des
personnes qui entendait
parce que tout de suite on s'est sentis
senti mal à l'aise
et puis tout si tu apprendras demander
des nouvelles
imaginez on fait arrêter dans la rue par
quelqu'un qui vous dit qu'il est en
prison avec votre père donc c'était
c'était quelque chose de c'est une
déchirure de plus oui c'est de nouveau
un petit canif alors à ce moment là ça
va un peu mieux pour votre frère
zacharias il rencontre fanni qui est
blonde à la peau blanche et aux yeux
clairs et ils ont une histoire d'amour
qui va d'ailleurs duré dix ans mais les
parents de fannie sont un racisme
affligeant ils l'aiment pas c'est ce que
dit fanny c'est ce que disait zakaria
moi j'ai pas vu de démonstration de
racisme virulent voyez c'était une
indifférence et comme je le disais dans
le livre peut-être que fanny à a le tort
de de dévoiler les propos qui se
tiennent chez elle dans l'intimité de la
maison donc il ya un mépris qui s'est
installée une distance
au début nous vous savez quand on était
plus jeunes on pensait que les gens
racistes
c'était uniquement des gens qui
n'étaient pas cultivé que c'est des gens
qui qui qui avait peur de l'autre qui
n'avait jamais été en contact avec
l'autre donc on pensait que de montrer
tel qu'on est de se montrer tel qu'on
était d'essayer d'être ouvert de
communiquer d'aller vers l'autre ça
faisait tomber les barrières non non non
c'est pas aussi simple c'est plus
compliqué que ça à l'époque vous
découvrez que votre frère à carrias
n'aime plus votre mère oui c'est
terrible vite qu'ils la regardent mais
pas comme on regarde une mère il la
regarde froidement avec distance avec
recul faut dire qu'ils avaient des
conflits il avait dès l'âge de 14 ans il
avait des config mais très très dur moi
je ne comprenais pas âgées j'ai jamais
compris sans il était capable de
de s'engueuler de se disputer de 18h à
2h du matin c'est épuisant
surtout quand ça se passe tous les jours
alors parlez beaucoup avec votre mère
pour se disputer apparemment mais votre
mère vous a jamais parlé à rabat la
maison déjà je me rends compte
qu'effectivement on parlait pas arabe à
la maison on connaissait pas les gens de
notre famille on connaissait pas notre
culture on connaissait pas notre
tradition le peu de fois où on a posé
des questions par exemple quand on veut
parler on veut apprendre une langue
on a besoin d'être mis en confiance si à
chaque fois que vous voulez apprendre
une langue
pourquoi vous dit un mot de travers ou
connaissez mal on se met à rire dans sa
coupe toute velléité quoi votre mère
vous a jamais parlé non plus de religion
la religion musulmane je m'étais jamais
été apprises
ce qui a fait que vous n'avez pas de
repères en fait c'est on était ignares
on va dire ce qui est on dignard je dois
dire que je connaissais enfants je
connais c'est plus le catholicisme que
la religion musulmane
en alsace il y avait pas de séparation
de l'église et de l'état
je me rappelle à l'école primaire et ben
on aller au catéchisme
moi je dis aux curés je suis musulman
mais bon à part le mot musulman je
savais pas très bien ce que ça ce qu'il
y avait derrière et puis bon il me
racontait des histoires bon je savais
donc les gens fêter noël je savais
pourquoi il y avait la toussaint je
savais pourquoi
mais le ramadan je savais pas pourquoi
la fête de la naissance du prophète
mohamed je savais pas pourquoi pourquoi
les gens faisaient la prière comment il
faisait la prière je ne savais pas
pourquoi des ignares donc vous
fréquentez pas beaucoup d'arabes vous
dit même que votre mère était c'est
xénophobe et que ce qu'elle disait dans
la bouche de d'un un français de souche
sera paru comme des propos extrêmement
xénophobe limite front national quoi
mais écoutez moi quand j'étais quand
j'étais plus jeune avec mon père ça nous
gêne et ça ne gênait beaucoup gênés
beaucoup je n'avais pas peut-être les
mots pour dire si tels propos et
xénophobes ou pas mais on se sentait
très mal à l'aise
pourquoi parce que dès qu'il y avait un
maghrébin c'était les moqueries
c'était c'était c'était nous renvoyer
une image qui est pas une image positive
donc on sentait mal à l'aise nous en
fait alors vous n'êtes pas non plus
intégrée évidemment parmi les
les français de souche et vous raconter
dans votre livre une anecdote assez
terrible vous êtes à mulhouse vous êtes
rue kaysersberg dans un espace vert qui
est en bas de l'immeuble où vous habitez
et vous jouer aux billes avec des petits
copains en rentrant de l'école jusqu'au
jour où le petit garçon nous dit je ne
peux pas jouer avec vous alors mes
parents me l'ont interdite alors vous
dites pour ce soir non c'est pour tout
le temps pourquoi parce que vous êtes
des [ __ ] ça c'était là notre première
expérience par un proche et c'est vrai
que moi ça ne m'est restée en mémoire
parce que c'était quelqu'un que je
côtoyais c'était quelqu'un avec qui je
m'amusais c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
rigolais et puis du jour au lendemain il
ya eu ces changements cette cassure mais
ça c'est de la gnognotte à côté d'eux
d'autres expériences
alors il ya un événement important c'est
le 14 juillet 1989 vous êtes victime
d'une agression raciste à narbonne donc
quand vous courrez voir les policiers
pour chercher un abri pour qu'ils vous
protège
il vous accueille avec des gaz
lacrymogènes parce que pour eux un arabe
est coupable d'office à la salle
zacharias le voit il en souffre presque
plus que vous et là aussi ça a dû faire
partie des petites fêlures qui ont tout
à fait un type qui m'arrêtent dans la
rue mme il me tape sur l'épaule je me
retourne mais une droite à soir de 14
juillet je m'en vais en courant au coin
de l'immeuble
je tombe sur une patrouille de police
qu'est ce que je fais le réflexe j'ai la
bouche en sang
je m'arrête je demande de l'aide ouais
puis là il reste ils me regardent et
puis le type il arrive il veut me finir
et puis un policier matraque par les
cheveux il me sort une bombe lacrymogène
et il me gaz je me sauve je m'évanouis
puis j'ai la chance que de mesures
devant un restaurant dans le cas il ya
des amis qui sont en train de dîner sont
sortis ils sont venus voir qu'est ce
qu'il y avait ils m'ont réanimer
il m'a emmené à l'hôpital et ils ont
fait ils ont fait fuir le type mais
c'est pas c'est pas le coup de poing qui
m'a fait mal et c'est pas le coup de
poing qui m'avait révolté ce qui m'avait
révoltés à l'époque parce que j'étais
j'étais jeune j'étais un jeune homme
c'est le manque de réaction des flics
français jc que d'accord il y avait là
connu d'accord c'était le 14 juillet
d'accord il y avait du monde mais c'est
que entre deux le choix il a évité fait
forcément c'était moi ouais et et c'est
vrai que pendant longtemps j'en ai gardé
un ressentiment et pendant longtemps ça
tu es la confiance il a fallu plus
d'expérience plus de plus d'épreuves
pour relativiser alors zakaria souffre
plus que vous finalement de cette
mésaventure et puis après c'est la
guerre du golfe alors là d'un seul coup
il a le sentiment d'appartenir à l'autre
monde celui qui était attaqué par les
américains il jeudi il est je dirais on
est les étudiants et puis tout une sorte
une partie de la population parce que
moi je me rappelle les positions de jean
pierre chevènement il était il était
contre le l'attaquent en irak 1 il ya
d'autres moyens que de bombarder des
populations civiles
maintenant il faut raison garder on
était pas on n'était pas pour saddam
hussein ah non absolument pas la
dictature le gazage des populations
kurdes
on n'était pas pour ça nous ce qu'on
voyait uniquement c'était une population
civile qui allait se faire taper dessus
et en même temps que cela on avait des
gens qui il était là il s'éclate et ils
se répandent et en en réjouissances
presque devant le lot mis la grandeur et
la beauté des frappes chirurgicales qui
ont fait des massacres de populations
d'un jeu vidéo comme un jeu vidéo
les oubliés sont complètement qui
avaient des populations civiles derrière
sous les bombes c'est ce que veut éviter
notre ami marianiste pour ça qu'il est
parti à bagdad alors zacharias
fréquentes à ce moment là la cafétaria
de la cité universitaire de montpellier
il rencontre des étudiants étrangers
donc il est soumis sûrement à ce
moment-là certaine influence et une part
assez rapidement en angleterre et au
début il revient voir fanny tous les 4
mois au départ il revient assez souvent
finalement mais ils commencent à changer
votre épouse fouzia préparent le capes
donc elle fait des études lui lui
explique un jour où il revient comme ça
qu'il faut pas que les filles phase
d'étude à petit à petit devient étranger
avoue une certaine façon au départ avec
mon épouse fouzia on comprenait pas
fouzia elle a fait des études de
biologie la fin de troisième cycle de
neuropsychopharmacologie elle préparait
un capes de biologie les années
précédentes avant qu'il parte en
angleterre mon frère était le premier à
l'encourager faut savoir que mon frère
il n'avait qu'une idée qu'une obsession
c'était la réussite professionnelle
son objectif c'était monté une
entreprise qu'on fasse d'import export
entre les pays du maghreb les pays du
golfe et c'est pour ça qu'il était parti
en angleterre pour améliorer ses
connaissances en anglais donc quelques
mois plus tard on le voit revenir et
qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans son discours
en fait pourquoi tu fais ça de toute
façon reste à la maison c'était mieux à
la maison
et puis de toute façon tu sais les
femmes 1 après tout hein vous voyez
changé alors il se met à porter la barbe
il se rase le crâne
il commence à porter des pantalons à mi
mollet et un jour l'une de vos soeur
jamila s'habille pour sortir habillé
comme comment s'habille ici et zacharias
la regarde et lui dit mais tu vas pas
sortir habillé comme une [ __ ] dire que
là vous vous comprenez d'un seul coup
qui dépasse et l'autre côté moi quand
elle m'a raconté ça ça m'a fait mal au
coeur et je me suis dit qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui était vraiment brisé
chez lui moi j'ai pris ça vraiment pour
vraiment un signe de détresse alors il
avait été recruté par une secte
wahhabite et vous vous lui donnez à ce
moment là des brochures qui critiquent
le wahhabisme et et finalement au lieu
de le ramener dans le droit chemin si on
peut dire ça ne fait que renforcer sa
détermination je connaissais pas j'étais
pas du tout avertit mois par rapport à
cette secte de la secte wahhabite où les
coteaux beast j'étais pas du tout
avertira ça je connaissais pas
et puis donc je savais qu en angleterre
je lisais les journaux je savais qu'en
angleterre et des groupes extrémistes
je savais qu'il y avait des groupes bois
habite donc j'allais dans une mosquée à
montpellier il avait la documentation
sur des wahhabites je lui donne moi je
vais le réflexe mon frère c'est un
universitaire lorsqu'il veut s'informer
sur un sujet il se fait une
bibliographie
ils se constituent une documentation
donc à partir des informations que je
vais lui donner il va pouvoir avoir des
éléments pour être critique
moi c'est le raisonnement manif que
j'avais mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on
lutte contre une secte
oui là c'est l'échec assuré
quand on a quelqu'un qui est embrigadé
dans une secte il faut d'abord cultivée
la relation il faut cultiver les
sentiments l'attachement
car si par le coeur qu'on arrive à faire
sortir quelqu'un d'une secte
c'est pas par la raison dans un premier
temps mais la raison elle est là elle
est importante parce que quand on vient
avec les arguments et que l'on montre à
quel point le wahhabisme c'est une secte
qui est apparue il ya 250 ans et qu'on
montre à partir des arguments de la
religion que leurs propos leurs propos
d'excommunication des populations
entières leur propose de légitimation de
l'assassinât et du meurtre et que ce
sont des choses qui sont infondés qui
n'existe pas dans l'islam sunnite faut
savoir que les théologiens musulmans
sunnites
depuis 250 ans il montre du doigt et il
met en garde contre le wahhabisme
si on montre cette réalité là là la
réaction n'est plus la même mais vous
parlez du wahhabisme comme d'une siècle
enfin que c'est quand même la religion
officielle de l'arabie saoudite
officiellement en arabie saoudite
on appelle ça le royaume wahhabite c'est
un fait si on interroge les la
population d'arabie vont vous dire on
est à bali et quand l'idéologie où elle
habite pénètre en europe
c'est pas en disant on est où habite
parce que nous habitent ne sont pas
aimés ils vous disent ils disent la
population musulmane nous sommes
emballés à dire une des quatre écoles de
jurisprudence qu'on appelle l'islam
sunnite et par cette porte là ils vont
essayer de rentrer et petit à petit ce
qu'ils vont essayer de faire c'est faire
croire à la population musulmane à la
jeunesse musulmane qu'ils sont eux les
tenants et les garants de la légalité et
de la légitimité religieuse musulmane
alors vous vous êtes sunnite
tout à fait vous êtes
d'une tendance qui s'appelle léa bâche
est ce que vous nous expliquer en quoi
parce que vous savez les français
connaissent pas très bien la deuxième
religion de leur pays c'est quand même
un drame les ardèche
ce sont des sunnites qui ont peut-être
plus pris conscience que d'autres
d'accord qu'il fallait aider la
communauté musulmane à lutter contre
l'extrémisme
le problème c'est que les wahhabites
détiennent l'argent du monde musulman et
vous dites qu'ils occupent 90 % du
linéaire islamistes en vente libre
leurs livres sont ceux qu'on trouve le
plus le plus facilement en europe oui ça
c'était c'est une mais deuxième
constatation quand j'ai vu mon frère me
glisser des mains donc j'ai voulu aller
me me renseigner me documenter qu'est ce
que j'ai fait bien le réflexe je vais
dans une librairie maghrébine
là où pour 150 francs à l'époque 150
francs on ressort avec des bouquins et
puis quand on discute avec le libraire
et vous apprend que en réalité les
livres il paie pas on lui donne et on
lui dit battu les payera quand comme
quand tu veux je sais pas quel libraires
peuvent fonctionner comme ça donc
l'argent c'est important parce que le
fait c'est comme dans un supermarché
vous rentrez vous trouvez 80% des
linéaires qui sont remplis de
l'idéologie ou arabic économistes le
jeune qui est né en france qui comme moi
n'a pas dit s'il n'y a pas d'histoire
n'a pas connaissance de la culture
marveaux n'a pas de repères qu'est-ce
qui va croire il pourrait croire que
c'est représentatif du monde sunnite
alors ça n'a rien à voir est-ce que vous
pensez que les livres wahhabite
devraient être interdits à la vente en
france par exemple a tout à fait bien
sûr mais c'est pas l'unique moyen on
peut pas remplacer l'éducation c'est
c'est irremplaçable c'est une nécessité
moi je suis enseignant moi je veux le
bien moi je veux que les jeunes que je
forme au lycée ben ils soient utiles
pour eux mêmes pour leurs familles pour
la société j'ai pas envie qu'il se
laisse embrigadé par un groupe
extrémiste qui se fasse sauter ou qui
tuent des gens et je voudrais que les
gens de bonne volonté
eh bien il se révolte on veut aussi dans
quel sens bien qu'on sache que derrière
l'idéologie de la haine et la terreur ya
le wahhabisme ya l'idéologie c'est trop
tôt et qu'il ya des gens qui ont de
l'argent et qui pousse cela voudrait
qu'il ya beaucoup de zacarias moussaoui
dans les banlieues françaises
je ne sais pas mais je sais que
potentiellement il ya une
une vraie détresse sociale et que les
wahhabites et les adeptes de ses tubes
ils savent utiliser cette détresse
sociale pour capter les gens c'est sûr
qu'il faut un profil particulier c'est
sûr qu'il faut être réceptif c'est pas
tout le monde mais il ya plusieurs
niveaux vous savez il ya des rabatteurs
ce sont les adeptes de l'idéologie de
c'est trop tôt et puis après il ya ce
qui met les bombes et je sais qu'en
france il ya beaucoup de rabatteurs vous
croyez qu'en france aujourd'hui le
politiquement correct interdit d' d'en
parler de ça par peur de l'amalgamé pour
éviter finalement que les gens
considèrent tous les tous les musulmans
comme des terroristes en puissance
moi je pense qu'il faudrait il faudrait
casser ce tabou et il faudrait essayer
de lancer le débat mais moi j'ai
j'apporte ma pierre vous aussi d'autres
peuvent l'apporter
et c'est clair que si on casse ce tabou
là les choses vont aller on va pas
refaire le monde
non mais les choses vont un peu mieux
comment ça peut aller mais alors à
callas vous l'avais pas revu depuis 1995
vous avez un contact avec lui depuis son
arrestation
non il m'a adressé un message dans une
de ses lettres il me disait qu'il
m'embrasser et
mise à part ça non j'ai pas eu de
contact vous pouvez pas aller aux états
unis parce que vous craignez d'être
gardés par les autorités américaines
jusqu'au procès comme témoin donc que
vous n'y allez pas oui c'est pour ça oui
c'est pour ça ce qui est terrible avec
zacharias c'est que dans ses
déclarations il persiste et signe
dire que même maintenant où il au secret
dans une prison américaine
il a pas de repentir je vous fais pas
dire c'est terrible mois moi j'attends
le moment où peut-être il y aura un
recul qui sera pris par lui et lui
remettra en cause un peu les idéologies
qui l'a amené là où il se trouve et où
il manifestera un repentir il attend ça
avec beaucoup d'impatience
imaginez que votre frère zacarias
moussaoui regardent cette émission est
ce que vous avez quelque chose regardez
votre caméra est ce que vous avez
quelque chose à lui dire ben moi si je
pouvais voir mon frère en face de moi je
lui dirais que tout homme tant qu'il est
vivant il a la possibilité de changer et
que c'est pas parce qu'on a fait des
erreurs dans le passé que on peut pas
être meilleure et qu' il faut avoir le
courage de reconnaître ses erreurs et
d'expliquer en quoi on a fait des
erreurs parce que dans sa situation son
cas c'est devenu un cas qui est
emblématique
et il faudrait pas qu'elle ait d'autres
qui suivent son exemple merci
[Applaudissements]
alain chabat est ce que oui ou non vous
avez pécho paris s'il tonne la semaine
dernière à los angeles
non j'étais à tourcoing est ce que oui
ou non on finit winter vous a mis dans
son cv à la rubrique expérience
professionnelle non mais c'est une vraie
bonne vague
est ce que oui ou non vous avez perdu 10
kilos non
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes toujours
faim qui fraîche challah oui je suis
funky frêche je suis je j'ai l'apparence
comme ça dans un garçon un petit peu un
petit peu gros un petit peu mais à
l'intérieur je suis un grand noir
extrêmement musclé que l'exemple que
c'est très bien
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes heureux
- depuis que vous arrêter mais sinon oui
je sais ce genre est ce que oui ou non
jacques devenu producteur de films à
hollywood
je suis j'essaye d'apporter la merguez à
hollywood en ce moment je travaille là
dessus
l'intéressant est ce que vous n'en
depuis cinq ans on pouvait choquer
toutes les actrices françaises que vous
voulez à la oui bien sûr est ce que oui
ou non dominique farrugia vous surnomme
le serpent est lunettes
oui mais
il m'énerve ces thèmes ont sûrement le
serpent lunettes est ce que oui ou non
les nuls vont se reformer un jour
peut-être
en tout cas nous sortons un dvd objectif
à la rentrée est ce que oui ou non
chantal lauby a baisé avec un des nuls
non et c'est pas on assez franchement on
a essayé voulait rien savoir
est ce que oui ou non canal est avant
tout une aventure humaine merveilleuse
dans laquelle vous avez vécu les plus
belles années de votre vie et qui nous a
permis d'accomplir vos rêves les plus
fous
merci oui canal est avant tout une
aventure merveilleuse way dans laquelle
j'ai pu accomplir mes rêves les plus
fous je me souviens plus bien du milieu
et
rappelons que l'ana g de alain chabat
donne habitat canal
ah ouais ouais j'ai trouvé ça en
cherchant en rangeant des caisses
je vais ça fait que la semaine laurent
est ce que oui ou non vous avez retrouvé
l'esprit canal avec stéphane bern amor
amor est ce que oui ou non vous la péter
un peu depuis astérix
je me la suis toujours péter c'était
avant la crise ni après à peine plus en
plus est ce que oui ou non vous étiez un
danger pour le gouvernement
et c'est pour ça qu'on a essayé de
descendre le film de robin ne rien dire
non est ce que oui ou non on pourrait
faire le chien là maintenant
[Musique]